I think I'm ready to start writing hi
I'm Jonathan and I'm a producer on bring
me
I love fascinating foods and one thing
that I find super interesting is
hand-rolled
ice cream there's just something so
mesmerizing by the way you roll it
crunch all the ingredients together pour
in the cream even the way you hold the
spatula so today I'm at holy Rowley in
Arcadia California where I'm gonna be
learning how to roll ice cream by hand
hi everybody I'm rocky I am a supervisor
here at Holy Roller ice cream Arcadia
and we specialize and basically
specialty rolled
ice cream we make all of our bases here
inside the store and we can customize
basically any flavor that you want you
just choose your ice cream choose your
toppings inside the ice cream and choose
your toppings on top hi dozen we really
be good these are spatulas how do you
normally like this
this or like this all of the above you
hold them like this like this and like
this
so we can roll the ice cream we are
gonna make the peanut butter cup is that
one of the easier ones nope it's more
challenging nice the ingredients are
gonna be the vanilla base the peanut
butter cup and the peanut butter itself
we take a scoop of the peanut butter
slap it on the peanut butter
cup and slap it on the pin and push it
down like that now you start chopping
and this just gets a little bit
difficult because as its on the pan it's
already breathing and then you put one
spatula flat and then we use the other
one to crush it helps you get your anger
out then you take the vanilla base and
you pour it all around and now we do the
scoop and the push so you scoop any push
mm-hmm push push and then in between
that you're gonna keep chopping so that
the ice cream gets mixed in with the
ingredients itself and do you want to
make sure that it isn't freezing too
quickly oh you're moving so fast
keep going around until all the liquid
has been frozen and then when it's all
kind of standing up by itself take it on
one spatula uh-huh Taleban down and then
you start spreading you want to make a
big rectangle take whatever is on the
spatula fill in all of the holes and
make sure you're getting the middle once
you kind of start to see it getting a
little bit more matte on the top is when
you know that you can start rolling it
there's one side without a little divot
there's one side with that's the side
you want to roll it take it about
three-quarters in so the rolls aren't
too tall and you go for it so see this
one started to shatter a little bit it
means that it's too cold and then
usually when that happens we tend to
just tilt the spatula up a little bit
more so that it's easier for the ice
cream to fall over
and then we just put it straight into
the bowl because it would be difficult
to squeeze that in here put the tongs
inside the bowl and so I can just
squeeze it in there
same thing with the middle oh oh she's
having a hard time so whenever this
happens I like to just hit it so this is
the peanut butter cup ice cream it's
beautiful I don't know easy enough
I think so you should be able to do it I
can do it it I have faith in you stuck
with peanut butter on the cup okay
goodbye
oh that is a little different I told ya
no oh sorry the ice cream time Oh ice
cream yeah oh yeah you are not doing bad
wow really yeah okay one more time
around with this you can punch okay yeah
that way okay I think you're ready to
start spread angle time yeah
[Applause]
that was a good cop thank you you want
to kind of start with the tip of the
spatula so that you pushing the ice
cream over yeah like that
my rectangle sucks it's fine okay
I'm ready to roll let's Rumble
Wow look at her she's so cute why
yeardley when you career that you are
doing fantastic wow I really was
expecting this to go south handy-dandy
comms place it here next to it real nice
and pretty look at that
well I think it's time for a challenge
now we go head-to-head all right you're
on
I'm on oh you're not
today is gonna be the day where the
amateur surpasses the pro we're
switching flavors we are we're gonna do
the strawberry gram instead and it's a
little bit easier than the peanut butter
cup only because there's technically
less crushing and might be the part well
I mean you're still crush but it's it's
smoother so you don't have as many like
rocky pieces inside of it that's rocky I
have a question what what close to toots
Winnie whoever finishes first and
whoever's looks the best well let's do
this who makes the better
oh one whole mess I'm gonna have to
clean up
okay I'm going rogue I'm not following
in techniques anymore
I ran out of ice we have the same amount
mine's not really a rectangle okay
let's roll than I do we have the same
amount of love said exactly my click
clear winner first time ok for this
moment
I had a few obstacles to overcome
machine flaws the ice cream was off the
machine
I think it was the machine it was a
while but I learned a lot today thank
you so much fun I think you did a
fantastic job and especially under a
time crunch I mean at least their roles
we are indeed rules shall we eat this
ice cream shop is yours thank you for
getting ice cream with me Oh any time
[Music]
[Music]